okay here's an interesting story in 1990
an amendment was made to the Clean Air
Act in the United States aimed at
reducing the release of carbon monoxide
into the atmosphere to reduce air
pollution part of the law mandated that
gasoline and automobiles must have a
minimum amount of oxygen at additive a
chemical compound that helps fuel burn
more completely and thus limits the soot
and carbon monoxide released into the
atmosphere from 1992 to 2005 the most
popular oxygen for gasoline was methyl
tert-butyl ether or MTBE but in the
early 2000s a number of cases of MTBE
contaminating groundwater raised
concerns about its health effects
gasoline additive MTBE was first noticed
in the water in 2001 residents
reportedly got sick from drinking it
2004 both New York and California banned
the chemical from the state a big blow
considering Cali and NY accounted for 40
percent of nationwide MTBE consumption a
year later in 2005 23 more states
followed suit and banned the chemical in
that same year Congress passed the
Energy Policy Act which did not include
provisions to shield MTBE manufacturers
from those pesky water contamination
lawsuits and so with no protections
against growing public outcry the
country was forced to turn to
alternative ways of gasoline oxygenation
what filled the void was ethanol in the
last 10 years
ethanol manufacture and consumption has
risen like a rocket ship in 2010 the US
was the world's top ethanol producer
with thirteen point two billion gallons
or 57 point five percent of global
production ethanol is a biofuel which
means that it's a fuel produced from
living organisms in the case of America
the majority of ethanol comes from corn
the increase of demand for ethanol
driven in part by US legislation to
reduce air pollution has led to the
widespread expansion of cropland to
produce more corn especially in the
Midwest and Great Plains right smack dab
in the middle of the monarch butterfly
migration path whoa not the butterflies
dude indigenous to North America and
instantly recognizable to anyone who
lives here the monarch butterfly it
makes the
longest and most spectacular migration
of any insect in the world every winter
the monarch population flies 2,500 miles
from its many homes in America and
Canada to specific warm sites in Mexico
and Southern California on the way it
lays eggs for the next generation but it
can only lay them in one place milkweed
plant
it's an odd feature of nature that
monarch larvae eat milkweed leaves and
nothing else but they do and as much as
monarch larvae love that milkweed
farmers hate it
it's a weak weed reduces yield and less
yield means less money so in addition to
clearing pristine lands in the Great
Plains where milkweed thrives farmers
have increasingly adopted genetically
modified crops which are resistant to
herbicides like round not to introduce
you to round up quick pro this product
is produced by Monsanto it is a
post-emergent non-selective herbicide
naturally this poses a serious danger to
the population of the monarch butterfly
which has fallen a mind-blowing 90
percent since its peak in 1996 the
losses of milkweed are only part of the
reason why the monarch population is
crashing the legal deforestation of
their winter home in Mexico and a couple
years of bad weather have hurt their
ability to make the long journey south
and north again but even when conditions
are right monarchs now have to fly
farther and longer to find places to lay
their eggs often they die before making
it there no one is talking about the
extinction of the monarch just yet but a
56% loss of monarch population in one
year 2013 is nothing to sneeze at both
America and Mexico have pledged to do
what's necessary to save the monarch and
if you want to help you can learn how to
build butterfly gardens in your backyard
I don't know about you but to me this is
an amazing story a story of the
unintended consequences of human action
on earth legislation passed in the u.s.
years ago to fight pollution has come to
pose a serious long-term threat to one
of nature's loveliest creatures it's
certainly a cliche to say everything in
nature is connected
but it is